Counter-Strike 2 is coming we know this
what we don't know is when and in what
state I think we can all agree that long
term chances are high that CS2 will
shape up into something great I think we
can also agree that short term it being
in admittedly rough shape is sort of
concerning CS2 isn't just succeeding CS
go it's outright replacing it so what
happens if the update rolls out an
entire professional scene is waiting for
it and it just isn't ready
[Music]
all right so CS2 it's fair to say that
if you've been following the trajectory
of valve's newest addition to the
Counter-Strike franchise you've probably
noticed that the beta has been a little
bit
scuffed from insane smoke blooms to
doorstep offering invincibility to
people becoming flying specters of death
CS2 is undeniably in need of some love
[Laughter]
even basic furniture grade features like
movement and tick rates are being widely
regarded as shaky unfinished and on the
whole subpar shooting in CS2 is
definitely superior but the movement
is so much better in this in csgo
they're so much better valve have of
course shipped fixes and whether it's
still subpar is Up For Debate valve came
out right with that post whatever it was
two days ago with the with the update
right and they said like we matched
movement one to one between CS go CS2 I
don't know if you've had a chance to try
it yet uh I did and honesty I'm sorry
but it's not csgo yet you still don't
feel it's CS go no it's better it's
better but no but I'm not here to farm
Impressions by on CS2 really
I'm not okay I mean I'm a little bit but
I love CS2 I genuinely think that the
changes that it promises to bring are
fantastic the thing that I want to talk
about is the short term the thing I want
to talk about is time as many of you
probably know valve famously hate public
deadlines they never ever said them they
just release things if and when they
feel like it the problem is that this
time around they did set a deadline
summer 2023 indeterminate as that is
it's still a deadline at some point
between now and the 23rd of September
the last day of summer valve are
supposedly releasing CS2 in its entirety
and it's just not at all clear that it
will be ready in time so even if they go
late summer
it's means like in maximum two months it
is gonna be out yeah and I'm really
scared about how can you fix
all these feelings in two months now
normally this wouldn't be such a big
deal games released in abysmal States
all the time Counter-Strike included in
fact there is a long storied history of
Counter-Strike sequels being downright
unplayable at launch those who played
the Cs go beta may remember that it was
famously dog so dog in fact
that it sent players crawling back to
vote source and 1.6 in fact throughout
all of counter-strike's history there's
been this sort of elitist impulse to
return to the olden times there are even
some Ultra feral hipsters out there who
will have you believe that
Counter-Strike peaked in and around 1.5
which like I'm a 1.6 elitist don't get
me wrong I still think 1.6 is better
than go but 1.5
that's a little much in my opinion
anyway the point is that whether or not
you subscribe to such elitism it was
sustainable the reason for this is that
valve released these successors as
Standalone titles it didn't matter that
condition zero or Source were
because you could always go back to the
OG and people did in fact the golden or
platinum age of competitive 1.6 didn't
come around until in and around 2010
2011 over half a decade after source's
release so again if the new game sucks
who cares we'll just keep playing
tournaments on the old one
but here's the thing this time we can't
which brings us to the much larger
issues surrounding cs2's release it's
not a sequel It's an update it's
replacing CS go last time it took valve
years to finally get Global Offensive
into a place where the community
regarded it as a worthy successor to 1.6
and don't get me wrong those Growing
Pains sucked but that was also a
different era of Esports major stadiums
weren't filling tens of thousands of
people and buyouts weren't reaching six
if not seven figures it was
understandable in a sense that CS go
still had to go through certain growing
pains after all Esports was still in its
teens now orgs are dishing out crazy
amounts of money roster shuffling in
anticipation of a game only a fraction
of the player base has played is riddled
with bugs feels worse than its
predecessor and oh yeah valve were
hosting a million dollar major for it in
eight months now look I am not
suggesting that CS2 is or that it
won't get better or that again the
changes it promises to bring won't
benefit Counter-Strike tenfold in the
years to come CS2 is undeniably on the
right track and a sponge rightly ranted
on HLT we confirmed the CS2 beta is in
better shape than the Cs go beta ever
was it's gonna take a little bit of time
we've just moved to a brand new engine
and we're in the beta and the game
already feels infinitely better than
Source ever did or CS go in the early
stages ever did that said right now in
the immediate I don't think it's unfair
or alarmist to wonder what happens if
valve just released this thing in the
next two months and it's just not ready
it was valve's decision to try and swap
out one game for another Indiana Jones
style and while I applaud them for it
and recognize that it's awesome and
ambitious what happens if they just bid
off more than they could chew the
program is that valve is not giving us a
new contest right they're giving us an
updated version of csgo so what and csgo
is not gonna be available anymore so buy
that what they are doing I mean from a
player you are telling me I'm not gonna
be able to play CS go anymore it's gonna
be CS2 and it's gonna be a better
version of csgo the program right now
it's like it's Kanda like csgo but it's
actually worst
but so this is a big risk for valve yeah
a simple scenario is they'll figure it
out they have to Counter-Strike earns
valve tens of millions in Revenue per
year and they're the tech gods of gaming
hell if they could figure out how to
Port over all of our skins there's
nothing we can't do the crazier scenario
is CS2 comes out where places go and is
just not up to Snuff periods of
transition are always rough and there
are absolutely going to be things around
game balance and infrastructure that
just take time to fix but there's no
world in which CS2 comes out and it's
just dog and we all just beg to go back
to CS go not for long anyway the games
are just way too similar as for how long
it takes them to iron out these
deficiencies I just I don't know there
really is a big question mark around
when this thing will be ready and how
seamlessly it will replace go from a
competitive standpoint I'm sure that
valve are working tirelessly but
ostensibly once this update comes out
There's No Going Back well I mean that's
not true we can always just go back to
1.6
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock